اربعه
معركه عسكريه مستعره وتصميم روسيه على
تحقيق اهدافها في الجانب الاخر من
المواجهه دعم غربي متواصل لاوكرانيا
التدفق كل الاسلحه الغربيه لا يتوقف لكنه
لا يكفي لترجيع كافتيكيف في ميزان المعركه
مع موسكو
وفقا لخبراء عسكريين تمتلك القوات
الاوكرانيه معدات واليات عسكريه تتميز
بالتنوع والتطور الى جانب وفره في خزائن
سلاح مدعوم من الغرب لكنها تفتقر الى
انظمه صيانه وامداد تواكب هذا الدعم ما
يجعل هذه الترسانه دوما في وضعيه عدم
استغلال امثل لغياب القدره على تصنيع
الذخيره الخاصه بها
تشير التقارير العسكريه الى زياده في
عمليه التدريب للجنود الاوكرانيين من
الغرب مصحوبه بحملات تعبئه واسعه للمجندين
لكنها لا تتمتع بوجود قاده من ذوي الخبرات
التي لا يمكن الحصول عليها الا بمرور
الزمن والتجارب
ليست اوكرانيا وحدها التي تمتلك نقاط ضعف
روسيا تمر بمشكلات تتعلق بقدرته بعض
الاسلحه السوفيتيه الى جانب حشد وتجنيد
الافراد لكنها في الوقت ذاته تمتلك سلاحا
جويا وبحريا فائق القدره الى جانب فريق
انتاج وتصنيع واصلاح للمركبات العسكريه
وقد في الدبابات والمدفعيه
ووفقا للخبراء العسكريين فان ميزان
التكافؤ بين روسيا واوكرانيا يفتقر
للتوازن حتى اللحظه الحاليه لن تتمكن
اوكرانيا من الانتقال من حاله الدفاع
العسكري الى الهجوم فما زالت تعاني من خلل
في اساسيات تكوين وحدات الهجوميه قادره
على تحقيق نصر في عمليه عسكريه قد يطول
امدها
علي السمان العربيه